all right but we start off this
half-hour with the sexual assault case
against actor Kevin Spacey which could
be in jeopardy after his accuser invoked
his Fifth Amendment right against
self-incrimination on the witness stand
now 21 year old man claims Spacey got
him drunk and groped him at a bar on the
Massachusetts island of Nantucket three
years ago before invoking the fifth the
accuser testified yesterday that some
text messages on his cell phone from
that night are now missing those
messages apparently were not included in
screen shots he sent to police after
filing the report I have tried to go
back and find the conversations and do
to a variety of circumstances they were
not there those circumstances were not
related to any deletions no they did not
Kevin Spacey has denied the allegations
our legal analyst Ricky Clayman is here
again Ricky welcome back what is what is
the the accuser taking the fifth mean
for the this case against Kevin Spacey
well if you take the fifth at a hearing
and all of your testimony is stricken
which is what the judge did how are you
then going to waive the fifth and go and
testify a trial so often does a victim
take the fifth I have never in all of my
years of trying or covering cases seeing
a sexual assault victim take the fifth
so it was extraordinary and I think it
not the prosecution for a Luke they
could have never anticipated this is
typical for all of the testimony all the
evidence to be thrown out know what
happened here was a surprise to me
because I thought that the judge could
have ruled that up till the time he took
the fifth it would stand because he
waived the Fifth Amendment privilege he
testified for quite some time in detail
one of the problems however with his
testimony is the detail is often about
the fact that he doesn't remember things
it's one thing that he may have been too
drunk because he claims
it's basic applying him with drinks on
that night back in July 2016 but it's
another thing that he has almost no
memory of the last three years that is
in terms of his dealing with the police
is talking to his mother his father his
friends so when you keep saying I can't
recall I can't recall I can't remember
does that make you suspicious as a
prosecutor well it just makes me wonder
what has been going on for this young
man during the last three years in the
most important matter in his life so the
prosecution is dealing with what I would
conclude is a very reluctant witness and
things got very testy with his father
that the boy's father and the judge and
then the mother was on the stand there
were things that she couldn't remember
either well the boys dynamic in the
courtroom well the dynamic in the
courtroom because I watched it yes we
had a live feed of it the dynamic in the
courtroom was you had a very angry
father who was very angry with Alan
Jackson the defense lawyer because Alan
Jackson was really making headway
throughout the day this was the defense
day and they were very powerful and very
well prepared so the judge was gonna
hold him in contempt if he wouldn't
answer the questions the mother on their
hand says well yes I did delete things
from the phone because I wanted not to
show my son Vasiliy activities but the
defense needs that information the
defense has a right to be able to test
the credibility of the alleged victim
and if they don't have the information
that's really a violation of due process
does it look better for Kevin Spacey
today you know when the charges first
came it was a little shocking lost a
couple jobs yes he did and yes it looks
much better for Kevin Spacey today
because the judge actually invited kevin
spec evan Spacey's lawyer to file a
motion to dismiss Wow all right Ricky
Clayman thanks very much